when I'm working on the road getting a
good night's sleep is key that's why you
should put myself in bed by 10 p.m. and
stay up until about 3 or 4 a.m. I can
youtube videos and trying to quiet my
brains anxiety thoughts about my endless
views of failure sometimes else to look
up the instagrams of the people on
Vanderpump rules just to see if they're
real people but some people say the
health magazines say getting three to
four hours of sleep at night is great
all things in moderation so I pop out of
bed ready to attack the day like a lion
next it's on to breakfast I like to keep
a lot of healthy foods around because
it's really easy to get tempted when
you're on the road eight times up three
I start my day with a vitamin just for
energy and etc then it's on to a light
meal to wake up my digestive system to
say what's up weird tubes in my stomach
time to wake up suckers then it's on to
some light cardio and stretching to wake
up the rest of the body and really set
me up for a great day then it's on to
pick out my outfit for the day I'm
quirky and weird and usually let myself
choose whatever I'm feeling that day
today I'm feeling the clothes I slept in
they're not the dirtiest thing I've ever
worn in my life and that works for me
now it's on to taking a shower getting
my makeup done for the day showers are a
great time to relax and reflect on your
life in general now time for makeup
looks like I slept in mine for the night
before most of it's still there bonus
now to think about brushing your teeth
and remember that we have gum by this
point I'm usually feeling pretty good
I'm ready to answer some emails once I
open my inbox I realize there's a lot of
emails that are
myself up in the answer last night and I
didn't and there's a lot of people I
haven't responded to and this is feeling
like a crushing heavy overwhelming
feeling and I just don't want to do it
so I won't do it the anxiety is
comforting and familiar once all that's
done I finally have some me time to do
something comes up I'm light and that's
my morning routine when I'm on the road
remember all things in moderation stay
balanced and never stop
it's been gone for 20 20 yeah